μαςδικών ανθηλτισμό τότε είναι άλλη φόρμολα αν θέλεις καιταδύο πο έραγάλης μας ικάνα θλδισμό σε
αυτά τα θήματα που θα ζου βγάλουν μεγάη βάσει και θα ζου βγάζουμε στην πυραμήρα
μετά αμα ξεκινόχι για αμορά είναι πολύ πι ευκολο να βγούν πδέκα πρωταθλητές του μέλλων
θεωρίς ότι πρέπει να έρθει η πρώτη επιτυχία για να πασουν εκαταφωτα απάνωσου όχι μόνο
από τα μέσα ενημέρωσης αλλά και από τους αρμόδιους φορίς να ναδει πήρε στο πρώτο
λιπιαό μετάλλιο εκεί ένιωσες ότι ι αρμό διασχολούνται με τον παύλον κοντίδισίγουρα μενά το πρόλημαγμετάλλιο
να άλλάξαν παραπολλά πράγματα προς το θετικόν πριν αυτότ έχοδισί πάρα πολλές φολές το κονονικό
κούπιτο μεγαλύτεροκομμάτι τερος πάντω το τράβος ενικόγενιαμου κάτι που δεν έχω δηρώσει η διμόσια ι
πολύλιγες φρες το έχοποι ήταν ότι εγώ πριν αποσ ελημερακοστού ονδίνου είχαμέσα στο μιαλόμου ότιν
δεν αλλαζαν οι οροπίες δηλαδήνακόμμαικό γινα μου θα έπρεπε να πεντεί τα περισσότερα λεφτά για
να κάνειο παύλω ι σιοπλογιάεγώμεσα στο μυαλόμου ήταν ότι θα σταματούσα σπδαμαρίναι κινιά εξύψανει στο
μανισίο του αθαμτον ιξρα ότι πρώτοσμιστώς ε κάποια ν εμπιρία όχι κριβώς πρώτος αλλά θα
μποροσε να ταν μέχρι και πέντεχια δασθελλία στο μήνα η μουγκοσιδίο νετών εγθα ότι δε
θα ήθελα οικογένια μου να ξοιβιωσαχρηματα απάνωμου και εγώ να κάν αυτό πυ στηνοσία ένα
χόμε γιατί απ τιστιγμή που δεν πον μπορούσε αδώσ ναζήσω τότε ήταν μια ανασχόλησητά να
χόμηθα ήτα να δουλι ιά είναι και κάτι που ανταμήβεσ στο ερστής ημέρας θεωρίσω ότι
ίσως είναι καιρό στη χώρά μας για τις δστων αθλητισμόύ χρόνια ίσως ήρθεν η περίοδος
να αποκτήσει και οι κύπροσωπος άλλες χωρές ένα ι φυπουργείο αθλητισμού και εκείνο να σχολείται
με όλα αυτά να μείνετι ασκορπισμένα σε διάφορες υπηρεσίες